i can't imagine what it's going to be
like when i have my own child and get to
do that with them
desi perkins is officially a mom
the beauty vlogger and her husband
steven have welcomed their first child
together
a baby boy today's finally the day i'm
like crying cause i'm so emotional i'm
so excited the 33 year old
desi founder shared a series of videos
to her instagram story
while in the hospital before giving
birth
i was in pre-labor contractions for the
last two and a half days
just crazy desi and steven have been
extremely candid about their fertility
journey in recent years
after suffering a miscarriage in 2013.
i think what was really bothering me was
that every step of the way it was kind
of hitting
my soul and i felt myself not being
myself
anymore online and i think people could
feel that
and it almost had more power over me to
not talk about it
because it just felt like so much
my life that i've been sharing and so
much at that moment that i hadn't been
sharing and i just felt like it was a
way to take my power back over the
situation
the minute i did so many women came
forward
and talked to me about their stories
which was so
pumping i realized i'm not alone and a
lot of us feel alone during
these kinds of situations and it was
just a beautiful thing and i've never
felt so light after sharing at all
the couple announced they were expecting
in may
and have shared every step of the way on
social media of their in vitro
fertilization journey
i remember it was hard for me to
initially
accept that my best naturally was
just not enough for a viable pregnancy
i remember walking into the fertility
clinic and
seeing a sign that said expect
to expect and i wanted to start crying
just those words like it gave me so much
hope
eti spoke with the couple shortly after
announcing their pregnancy
and couldn't help but gush over the
excitement of becoming new parents
i've always dreamt about it and before
even
doing what i do now my dream was to be a
mother
and i have three brothers and i helped
bomb with them
and seeing how they've grown up and
things
took after uh me even things i've taught
them
it's just so special and you really
helped mold somebody
and it's just this unconditional love
that i have for them
and i can't imagine what it's gonna be
like when i have my own child
and get to do that with them
[Music]